Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
It's Question Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions from real nerdfighters.
Today, I'm going to be answering questions about love and romance
because,
you know,
I'm such an expert in the field.
[Intro music]
"Why am I so scared of rejection?"
Well, cause it's scary.
But the important thing to remember is that
EVERYONE is afraid of rejection,
they just don't seem that way because you're not busy living inside of THEIR thoughts.
"How do I know if my boyfriend is about to porpoise?"
Okay, the first sign I would look for
is that your boyfriend might be spending a lot of time in the water.
In fact, if your boyfriend is about to porpoise,
he might feel increasingly uncomfortable on land.
He may also start to look increasingly less human and more dolphin shaped,
but without the beak.
So yeah I would say if you notice any of that stuff,
then your boyfriend is probably going to porpoise pretty soon.
Oh wait.
You probably meant,
"how can I tell when my boyfriend's gonna PROpose?"
Mmm.
See why spelling matters.
The number one way to find out if your boyfriend is going to propose
is to ask him
and to talk about it
because it's weird that in our culture, for some reason,
marriage is something thrust upon women.
Like boys get to spend six months deciding if they want to get married,
but then the girl only has like ten seconds to say yes or no.
"Where are all the nerdy girls?"
Okay, dude, I don't want you to freak out,
but
they're right here.
Seriously dude, they're like watching us right now.
So yeah, just keep cool,
don't let them know that you know that they're here
and just, you know, play it confident.
"Is it weird having your first kiss?
I want to know because I think I might have my first kiss soon, and I don't want to be too nervous."
Okay, first,
I need to know if you mean like,
[mwah, mwah]
kiss,
or if you mean like
[bwok, bwok, bwok]
kiss.
By the way, that was not intended as a demonstration of proper kissing technique.
Because like the
[mwah, mwah] kiss,
no big whoop, nothing to be nervous about.
Though like [bla-la-la-la] kiss,
I'm gonna level with you,
you should be nervous about that.
Listen, it's probably gonna go poorly,
but if I can give you just one piece of advice:
the human tongue is a fantastic organ,
it's great for tasting,
without it, speech would be impossible,
but I would argue that it should not be the primary combatant of any kiss.
You know how the Marines always say that they're first to fight?
The tongue should not be first to kiss.
The tongue is like the Navy Seals.
You know, they're like in and out so fast,
you'll almost didn't even know they were there.
"What is the average number of times boys need to be broken up with
before they realize that girls don't like needy clingy boys?"
53.
"When two nerdfighters are in nerdfighter like, but then they need some time apart,
what is that phenomenon called?"
Breaking up.
"Is it still acceptable to ask someone out by writing them a note
in which you ask them to check either yes, or no?"
Do you think it's still allowed to write a note where you ask someone to check yes or no?
[Sarah]: It was never a good thing.
It totally worked with Jennifer Keene in third grade,
so back off.
[Sarah]: Um.. It works!
[Sarah]: I'm just saying that it's not, it's never been cool.
[Sarah]: It's always the whimp's way.
What do you recommend instead?
[Sarah]: Ask them.
With your voice?
[Sarah]: Yeah.
What if it quivers?
"How does a nerd win over a beauty queen?"
I don't know,
maybe I'd start by offering it peanut butter flavored treats.
No, wait,
that's how you win over a puppy.
I don't know how to win over a beauty queen,
I've never tried.
"I'm almost 18 and I've never been out on a date or had a boyfriend
and then I get really shy around guys,
is that weird or not weird?"
It's not weird
and you might be surprised to learn HOW not weird it is.
But, as far as getting shy around guys goes,
it's important to remember that they are, you know,
people
in exactly the same way that girls are people.
"Is it still called nerdfighter like if one person in the relationship is a nerdfighter and the other isn't?"
No.
That's called
"internerdial dating."
"Do guys really not like girls who are smarter than them?"
The venn diagram of guys who don't like smart girls
and guys you don't want to date
is a circle.
"Is breaking up over text message bad?"
Yes.
"How do you get over crushing shyness to ask a boy out on a date?"
Just ask.
I mean, actually, call him right now,
before you even finish watching this video.
Just call him
and say,
"John Green said I had to call you.
I like you a little bit
I want to go out on a date.
No big whoop."
Hank, thanks for being awesome,
and I'll see you tomorrow.